hola de nuevo en el vídeo pasado
estábamos analizando un escenario
bastante positivo en el cual mi vecino
había vendido su casa que era idéntica a
la mía en un millón quinientos mil pesos
entonces mi casa que inicialmente me
había costado un millón de pesos ahora
cuesta un millón y medio de pesos lo que
quiere decir que mi capital ha subido de
250 mil pesos a 750 mil pesos ojos tengo
un pasivo de 750 mil pesos de una
hipoteca que le debo al banco pues me
prestó para comprar mi casa de un millón
de pesos y este escenario estaba genial
porque yo había triplicado mi capital
ahora bien ya que triplicado mi capital
que puedo hacer con él no es dinero en
efectivo pues es un capital que está en
el valor de mi casa por lo tanto no
puedo salir a gastar melo luego luego en
este caso es lo que vamos a ver en este
vídeo es lo que se conoce como el
préstamo hipotecario con el valor
residual de la vivienda o dicho de otra
manera un préstamo con segunda hipoteca
y justo esto es lo que pasó en eeuu
durante mucho tiempo desde el 2001 hasta
el 2006 creo que actualmente no está
pasando
sin embargo este préstamo es más o menos
lo siguiente supongamos que yo vuelco en
el banco y le digo barco ha aumentado mi
capital hasta 750 mil pesos son ricos
sin embargo no tengo nada de efectivo
como podemos hacerle para que yo obtenga
efectivo de este capital que yo tengo ya
saben yo quiero vivir como gente rica y
entonces el banco me va a decir bueno te
voy a prestar una cierta cantidad de
dinero pero el único requisito es que tú
dejes el 25 por ciento de capital en tu
casa por lo tanto a mí me suena genial
esta idea entonces tengo el 75 por
ciento de capital de esta casa en un
préstamo entonces vamos a calcular
cuánto ese 75% de 1.5 millones de pesos
vamos a calcularlo 1.5 que multiplica al
75% esto es igual y bueno el 50 por
ciento de 1.5 son 750 mil pesos
y si a esto le sumó la mitad de 750.000
pesos me da un millón 125 mil pesos pero
ojo no hay que ponernos tan contentos
porque yo le debe al banco 750 mil pesos
por lo tanto vamos a hacer la resta si a
un millón 125 mil pesos yo le restó 750
mil pesos me van a quedar mejor vamos a
escribirlo para ver cuánto es lo que me
puede prestar el banco entonces tengo
1.125 menos punto 750 esto es igual a
apuntó 375 no es decir 375 mil pesos 375
mil pesos y es importante que mencione
que el banco no me puede prestar todo el
valor de mi casa ya saben en dado caso
de que no pague esta deuda o en dado
caso que no pague también lo que ya le
debía al banco por lo tanto ellos se
pueden cobrar con el valor de la casa y
ahora si yo estoy bien feliz porque ya
tengo mis 375 mil pesos y ya puedo hacer
con ellos un buen de cosas entonces ya
soy una persona que tiene dinero además
de tener una buena
y entonces es hora también de hacer un
nuevo una nueva hoja de balance para ver
qué es lo que está pasando por lo tanto
vamos a hacerla esta va a ser mi hoja de
balance la voy a hacer un poco más
grande para que vean bien qué es lo que
está pasando muy bien y entonces de mi
lado derecho yo tengo mis activos aquí
tengo mis activos y mis activos ahora
tengo una casa de un millón y medio de
pesos por lo tanto vamos a ponerlo aquí
tengo mi casa que todavía no me han
quitado no ha pasado nada raro tengo una
casa de un millón y medio de pesos esto
es de mi casa y por otra parte ya tengo
que el banco me prestó 375 mil pesos el
banco como él prestó 375 mil pesos en
efectivo por lo tanto lo voy a escribir
aquí 375 mil pesos en efectivo y bueno
del lado izquierdo recuerden que tengo
yo mi pasivo es decir mis deudas así que
vamos a escribir las de manera muy
ordenada primero tengo una hipoteca de
750 mil pesos tengo una hipoteca que con
la que empecé yo este vídeo de 750 mil
pesos
estos son mis pasivos y ahora también la
tengo el banco 375 mil pesos por lo
tanto como es una deuda también es un
pasivo y lo voy a poner aquí voy a hacer
otra línea y le debo el banco 375 mil
pesos para ya saben volverme una persona
con mucho dinero ok entonces recuerden
que para sacar el capital tengo que
hacer los activos menos los pasivos no
hay que olvidar esta fórmula que es
bastante importante por lo tanto vamos a
juntar mis pasivos y mis activos ahora
bien de activos tengo un millón
quinientos mil pesos más 375 mil pesos
lo que me da un millón 875 mil pesos
entonces de activos tengo un millón 875
mil pesos mientras que de pasivos tengo
750 mil pesos más 375 mil pesos lo que
me da un millón un millón 125 mil pesos
muy bien estos de pasivos y si yo hago
la diferencia me van a quedar 750 mil
pesos es decir un millón 875 mil pesos
menos un millón 125 mil pesos me da 750
mil pesos por lo tanto ya tengo mi
capital mi capital en esta hoja de
balance son 750 mil pesos y esto indica
que voy bien porque me tiene que salir
mi mismo capital que me salió en mi
primera hoja de balance entonces creo
que hasta ahorita todo va en orden y es
en este momento donde yo me siento
bastante adinerado porque nunca había
oído 750 mil pesos y más aún mi vecino
mi nuevo vecino que se acaba de cambiar
a la casa de enfrente de la casa que era
idéntica mía la cual compró por un
millón y medio de pesos él se acaba de
comprar un auto de lujo de 100 mil pesos
y yo como soy una persona centrada y con
los pies en la tierra entonces quiero un
auto de lujo de 100 mil pesos bueno no
esperen un auto de lujo tampoco me va a
servir porque también es un activo
entonces imagínense que mejor me gasto
100 mil pesos no se me voy de fiesta a
una fiesta interminable no no no mejor
me voy a ir de viaje a todo el mundo
porque mi vecino también se fue de viaje
a todo el mundo él se fue un año
completo a conocer los cinco continentes
y yo como soy una persona que me siento
con mucho
digo pues porque no también vamos a
viajar alrededor de todo el mundo y me
gasto también cien mil pesos y si te das
cuenta en ese momento las cosas cambian
porque cuando yo regreso después de un
año de haber viajado ya no tengo 375 mil
pesos en efectivo ahora solamente tengo
275 mil pesos en efectivo y bueno lo
vivido nadie me lo quita al final la
felicidad no es un activo o tal vez no
es un activo que podamos medir por lo
tanto solamente tengo 275 mil pesos en
efectivo y bajaron de activos ahora sí
sumamos un millón quinientos mil pesos
más 275 mil pesos me da un millón
setecientos setenta y cinco mil pesos
muy bien sin embargo ahora vamos a
fijarnos en nuestros pasivos nuestros
pasivos no van a cambiar el banco no me
va a decir oye sabes te fuiste de viaje
entonces me debes 100 mil pesos menos no
el banco me va a seguir cobrando todo el
dinero que me debía por lo tanto tengo
la misma cantidad de pasivos y si tengo
la misma cantidad de pasivos y los
activos cambiaron en 100 mil pesos por
lo tanto mi capital va a cambiar mi
capital es el que va a cambiar y ahora
no son 700 5
mil pesos son 650 mil pesos y lo que es
importante mencionar es que son 650 mil
pesos y bajo mi capital porque yo me
gasté 100 mil pesos en efectivo lo que
sucedió en esta ocasión es que de mil
750 mil pesos que yo tenía de capital
saqué 100 mil pesos los convertí en
efectivo y me lo gasté en un año de
vacaciones y es justo a esto a lo que se
refiere el préstamo hipotecario en el
valor residual de la vivienda o en dado
caso lo que habíamos definido como el
préstamo con segunda hipoteca y fue ese
tipo de préstamo lo que condujo a que la
economía de eeuu entrara en los años
2002 y 2003 en un estado expansivo lo
que pasó es que la gente aunque estaba
despedida seguía consumiendo en sus años
pues aunque no tenían trabajo pidieron
préstamos por el precio de su casa y con
todo ese dinero se compraron autos de
lujo se fueron de vacaciones se pusieron
ropa elegante etcétera y esto hizo que
la economía se expandiera en el
siguiente vídeo lo que voy a ver es
porque las casas aumentaron de precio de
que depende de qué pasa este proceso de
la moda de las casas pero eso lo voy a
ver con más calma en el siguiente vídeo
así que no
pierdan y nos vemos